hi guys it's gordon now this holiday  season make a wish is bringing you  the hottest online event of the year  literally  the good news is on december the 8th  tune in to my youtube channel for a live  event  that will warm your heart and trust me  my tongue  as shawn evans host of the first we  feast hot ones and i  are coming together again to help and  support an incredible  make-a-wish foundation that's right if  we can raise fifty thousand dollars by  december the eighth  i'm prepared to go into battle with more  heat than ever before  more importantly your support will drive  this challenge to a higher  and higher levels of spice while also  giving vital hope  to critical children all over the world  i'll be interacting live with you  and i'll have some amazing surprises so  are you ready  for another ring of fire i can't wait to  see you  on december the 8th  you